este centro de rescate de animales en
las afueras de kiev es diferente a la
mayoría
este León fue rescatado en la región de
idóneasca fue abandonado por sus dueños
fuimos alertados por los soldados que lo
encontraron como suele ser el caso vivía
en una jaula diminuta que medía dos por
tres metros con piso de cemento
es ilegal mantener animales exóticos en
cautiverio en Ucrania desde la invasión
a gran escala de Rusia está ong ha
salvado a más de 20 animales
abandonados a su suerte después de que
sus dueños huyeran de la lucha
para animales como leones tigres y osos
Se podría decir que esta guerra les ha
dado la oportunidad de llevar una vida
normal pero para los animales salvajes y
la fauna es un desastre cuando aterriza
un misil no queda nada con vida
los animales de los alrededores pueden
sufrir graves daños cerebrales no hay
mucho que podamos hacer para salvarlos
huyen se esconden y sufren una muerte
agonizante
nuestro centro de crisis estima que la
guerra ha creado daños al medio ambiente
por un valor de cuarenta mil millones de
dólares esa cifra aumentará después de
que los territorios ocupados hayan sido
liberados cuando podamos ver de primera
mano el daño allí
olena es diputada ella es parte de un
grupo de trabajo al que el gobierno ha
encargado para estudiar el impacto de la
guerra en el medio ambiente
hoy esta área ha sido completamente
liberada pero lo que sucedió tendrá
enormes consecuencias para el medio
ambiente
los recursos naturales como el aire el
suelo el nivel freático la vida Marina
todos están gravemente dañados podemos
reconstruir rápidamente puentes y casas
con ayuda internacional pero no podemos
arreglar la naturaleza con la misma
rapidez
el impacto real de la guerra sobre el
medio ambiente es muy difícil estimar
cuando termine los ambientalistas
estiman que pasarán décadas antes de que
la naturaleza retoma el control